reescribe la siguiente expresión como un
producto de exponentes positivos
posteriormente evalúa la expresión
cuando x es igual a 2 hagamos la primera
parte
quieren que escribamos la expresión con
un producto de exponentes positivos no
quieren que aparezca este exponente
menos 3 ni este exponente de 5 a la
menos 2 quien que reescribamos eso con
exponentes positivos y para hacer eso
hay que recordar que algo elevado a la
potencia negativa déjame escribirlo por
aquí sí tenemos digamos x elevado a la
menos 2 esto es igual a 1 sobre x
cuadrada y en general si tenemos a
elevado a la menos b esto es igual a 1
sobre ha elevado a la b podemos eliminar
ese exponente negativo si lo escribimos
como 1 entre el número elevado a la
potencia positiva a la menos b es el
recíproco de álabe apliquemos entonces
eso por acá x elevado a la potencia
menos 3 déjame hacer esto con distintos
colores x elevado a la menos 3
exactamente lo mismo que 1 sobre x al
cubo eso por definición luego tenemos x
5 elevado a la potencia menos 2 aquí
hacemos lo mismo 5 elevado a la potencia
menos 2 eso es igual a 1 sobre 5 al
cuadrado y finalmente tenemos que
multiplicar por x cuadrada no hay que
hacer nada porque el exponente es
positivo
así es que esto multiplicado por equis
cuadrada que hemos hecho lo primero ya
escribimos la expresión con un producto
de exponentes positivos ahora evaluamos
la expresión cuando x es igual a 2 así
es que donde veamos una equis vamos a
sustituir un 2 esto va a ser igual a 1
entre déjame hacerlo en el mismo color
esto es igual a 1 entre 2 al cubo que
multiplica a 1 entre 5 al cuadrado y que
multiplica a la vez a 2 al cuadrado ya
hemos sustituido el valor de x igualados
y vamos ahora a desarrollar las
potencias 2 al cubo hagámoslo
2 al cubo es 2 x 2 x 2 y esto es igual a
así es que este primer término es un
octavo que multiplica a 1 sobre 5 al
cuadrado 5 al cuadrado es igual 5 por 5
y esto es igual a 25 1 sobre 25 que
multiplica a 2 al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado
es vamos a hacerlo también por este lado
2 al cuadrado esto es igual a 2 por 2 y
esto es igual a 4
así es que esto es por 4 este 4 lo
podemos escribir como 4 sobre uno
hagamos ahora el producto de estas
fracciones primero multiplicamos los
numeradores uno por uno por cuatro es
igual a cuatro dividido entre el
producto de los denominadores esto es 8
por 25 esto es 4 por 25 es igual a 100
esto es igual a 200 muy bien vamos a
simplificar 4 entre 200 vamos a tomar
cuarta arriba y cuarta abajo cuarta
arriba es 14 abajo es 50 esto es igual a
1 sobre 50 y para que lo tomes en cuenta
hay una manera simplificada esta
expresión antes de llegar a esta última
etapa podríamos haber simplificado en
esta etapa de aquí
y déjame reescribir esto en este
producto
este término 2 al cuadrado lo podemos
escribir como 2 al cuadrado entre 1 el
numerador entonces lo podíamos escribir
como uno por uno por dos al cuadrado
esto es igual entonces a uno por uno por
dos al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado de 2 x 2
así es que esto sería 2 por 2 no
incluimos el producto de 1 por 1 pues el
producto uno por uno es 1 lo cual no
afecte este valor que tenemos el
denominador en el denominador tenemos 2
x 2 x 2
eso es 2 al cubo que multiplica a que
multiplica 5 por 5 que es 5 al cuadrado
y eso multiplicado por 1 que no
modifique este valor y aquí ya tenemos
varias simplificaciones obvias tenemos
aquí un 2 del numerador con un 2 del
denominador aquí tenemos otro 2 con otro
2 y al final de cuentas nos resulta 1
sobre 1 dividido entre 2 por 5 por 5 2
por 5 por 5 y esto es igual a lo que
tenemos abajo aquí tenemos 2 por 5 10
por 5 50 es 1 entre 50 que ya habíamos
obtenido previamente